- Trois jours que la tornade
a traversé la communauté
de Mayfield, raflant tout sur
son passage. Près de l'église
baptiste, complètement dévastée,
des bénévoles distribuentde la s
et surtout de l'eau.
"C'est bouleversant, dit-elle.
J'ai appelé ma mè e et j'ai
pleuré quand je suis arrivée
ici." Ricky Murphy,
le responsable, fait le tour
des maisons.ififif de Mayfield,
il n'arrive pas à croire que
cette ville, jadis si vivante,
soit anéantie.
"C'est venenent dérangeant,
dit-il, car c'est ma ville et,
maintenant, il n'y a plus rien."
Plus tôt dans la journée,
le gouverneur de l'État
Andy Beshear n'arrivait pas
non plus à contenir sa peine.
"Parmi les morts, 18 n'ont
toujours pas été identifiés",
dit-il. L'âge varie de 5 mois
à 86 ans, et six avaient moins
de 18 ans. Sans abri depuis
trois jours, Jennifer et sonfilr
leurs biens. Leur maison
est devenue inhabitable après
12 ans de vie de famille ici.
Ils vivent maintenant
dans un centre commercial
en attendant d'être relogés.
"Il y a eu beaucoup de larmes,
beaucoup de larmes, dit-elle.
Mais il faut garder un sens de
l'humour. On n'a pas le choix.
Heureusement, on a eu le soutien
de la famille et des amis."
La ville ressemble à une zone
de guerre. Un peu plus loin,
la police militaire interdit
l'accès à l'usine de bougies
qui a été complètement anéantie,
où au moins huit personnes
ont perdu la vie.
Nous sommes au centre-ville
de Mayfield, sur le boulevard
Commercial. Juste derrière moi,
l'égliseomomomomomplètement
détruite et tous les commerces
sur cette rue ont totalement
été rasés. La tornade est
passée vendredi soir et n'a
rien laissé sur son passage.
Encore aujourd'hui,
105 personnes sont
portées disparues.
"Le bilan final ne sera connu
que dans quelques semaines",
assure le gouverneur.
Mais au beau milieu de
ce paysage apocalyptique,
des enfants tentent de réparer
leur trampoline pour recommencer
à jouer, un signe que la vie
va finir par reprend
son cours malgré